السخاء الغربي مع اوكرانيا راويه يتواصل
فبعد حسم ملف الدبابات باعطاء الضوء
الاخضر لارسالها تسير واشنطن المزيد من
المساعدات قريبا هذه المساعدات ستكون
مختلفه هذه المره حيث تضم للمره الاولى
اسلحه لطالما طالبتك في الحصول عليها وهي
الصواريخ الابعد مدى فا الولايات المتحده
بصدد تجهيز حزمه مساعدات جديده تبلغ
قيمتها مليارين ومئتين مليون دولار على ان
يتم الاعلان عنها رسميا في وقت لاحق من
هذا الاسبوع وذلك نقلا عن مسؤول امريكي
حزمه قد تشمل ايضا معدات دعم لانظمه
الدفاع الجوي باتريوت وذخائر دقيقه
التوجيه وصواريخ جاب لينا المضاده
للدبابات وفيما يتعلق بالصواريخ ذات مدى
الابعد فان الامر يتعلق بالصواريخ معينه
تحديدا هي تعني همم يعني القطر الصغير هي
ارض جو ذات قطر صغير وهي صواريخ تصنعها
شركه بوينج ويتم اطلاقها من راجيمات
الصواريخ مثل هاي مارس ويتم توجيهها
بواسطه نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي ولكن
طبعا البعد اكبر ويمكنها التغلب على
التشويش الالكترونيه كما يمكن استخدامها
في جميع الظروف المناخيه ويبلغ مداها 150
كم ولها قدرات على المناوره والالتفاف
طبعا الفرق بين هاي مارس 80 كم وهذه
الابعد مدى ب 150 كلم وبفضل هذه الصواريخ
ستصبح اوكرانيا قادره على ضرب اهداف
لم تكن تصلها من قبل
في اوكرانيا يرتفع سقف المساعدات العسكريه
لاول مره حزمه مساعدات الامريكيه جديده
لاوكرانيا
صواريخ طويله المدى
المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه الاوكرانيا
تشمل معدات دعم لانظمه الدفاع الجوي
باترون
[موسيقى]
المضاده للدبابات
من المتوقع ان تشمل المساعدات ايضا
المركبات المقاومه للالغام وانظمه اطلاق
الصواريخ المتعدده الموجهه والذخيره
تبلغ قيمه تلك المساعدات مليارين ومئتين
مليون دولار
هذه المره فان الحزن القادمه ستتضمن ايضا
دعما طبيا من خلال كميه كبيره من المعدات
التي تكفي لتجهيز ثلاثه مستشفيات ميدانيه
ولحد الان فان البيت الابيض لم يعلن رسميا
عن هذه الحزمه التي قد يتغير محتواها قبل
ان يوقع عليها الرئيس الامريكي بنفسه وكما
هو الحال عندما يتعلق الامر باي حزمه
مساعدات غربيه فان روسيا تمدد هذه المره
ندد ايضا بهذا الدعم الذي سيؤجج الحرب على
حد وصفها الكرام لان قال ايضا ان تسليم
الولايات المتحده صواريخ ابعد مدى الى
اوكرانيا لن يغيره مسار الاحداث واكد في
الوقت نفسه عزما القوات الروسيه مواصله
هجومها مهما كلفه العمر
عايز كريستيانو
بالسلاح نحن لا نقسم الدول وفق مبدا
الجغرافيا ما نقول ان جميع الدول التي
تزود اوكرانيا بالاسلحه يجب ان تفهم اننا
سنعتبر هذه الاسلحه اهدافا مشروعه للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه